In this lesson, you'll use workflow and approvals to
automate manual tasks. You'll learn how to automate sending an
email, updating a field, and creating a task for users.
To do that, let's go back with Samantha and Andy.
>> We've got this really cool thing. This
dashboard that shows all this data about things like
money and the bands playing. And this is
interesting. This state about the tickets, the open maintenance
items that need to get fixed.
>> Yep.
>> And so, you know, we've thought about how to
collect the data? But really, is people doing these things?
>> Right.
>> We need to tell them, what to do.
>> So, we need to automate, actually
notifying the people involved with the maintenance
tickets, so they can get. Started you
know, fixing those problems right away, yeah?
>> I mean, so, can we make it so that you
know, a ticket gets created and then immediately a technician gets
alerted or something like that?
>> Definitely. So, what you're describing sounds a
lot like a workflow process. this is taking like
something that's a manual process and automating it
using a set of actions. So, in the case
of maintenance tickets. Maybe you want to update a
field, or send an email to this maintenance worker,
or give them a task. You can do
all that using, just point-click configurations on your workflow.
>> Cool,
let's do it.
>> Yeah.